quick stretch little snack
on april 8th
time to go for a ride
the wheel competition
begins
sonic
meet knuckles this is what we're gonna
do step one light taunting step two i
have no idea
i just got goose bumps
sonic the hedgehog 2 in theaters april
8th
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
[Music]
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you names
okay this is what we're gonna do step
one light taunting step two i have no
idea
[Music]
[Applause]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
[Applause]
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
you